bonjour merci d'être rare en direct avec
nous sur rt france quelle est la
situation sanitaire aujourd'hui au liban
alors bonjour on est en état d'urgence
sanitaire en fait depuis hier quand vous
l'avez déjà déclarée dans votre émission
le nombre de personnes contaminées en
fait frôlé la centaine avec trois décès
jusqu alors déclarée par le ministère de
la santé
il s'agit en fait de personnes jugées
vraiment vulnérable donc cet état
d'urgence sanitaire marquant cette
démesure au strict annoncées par le
gouvernement telles que le fait
d'appeler de mobiliser la population
donc arretez 1 chez eux à domicile à
mobiliser également le les
professionnels de santé notamment les
hôpitaux gouvernementaux mais également
les hôpitaux privés
il faut savoir qu'en fait la plupart des
cas actuellement sont dans l'hôpital
gouvernemental de rafic hariri qui a un
hôpital donc public au centre de
beyrouth et qui qui a déjà donc bien
prise en charge les cas de kovy 19 jusqu
alors recensé dans le pays
il faut également noter que pas mal
d'hôpitaux privés en l'occurrence
l'hôpital de l'hôtel dieu de france de
beyrouth ainsi que l'hôpital qui est
affiliée à l'université américaine de
beyrouth et donc les yeux et chats ont
pris 2,2 de même dont ils ont pris
l'initiative de créer des ailes privé
alors justement pour accueillir oui
justement une initiative privée mais
elle les autorités comment elle se
prépare très concrètement aujourd'hui
les autorités il faut dire à quelle
qu'elles ont déjà en fait mener des
campagnes de prévention de parts en fait
de diffuser des et des vidéos d
affiches des courts métrages concernant
les mesures d'hygiène de précaution ils
ont déjà pris des précautions notamment
au niveau des frontières là en fait on
va fermer l'aéroport de beyrouth à
partir de mercredi prochain ce sera le
18 mars les voies d'entrée du pays
terrestres aériennes maritimes seront
également fermés il faut noter toutefois
connu en presse commun en manque de
stock et d'équipements médicaux et de
médicaments
il donc là en fait l'état a fait appel à
des aides et des dons notamment d
organisation mondiale de la santé dng
aux ong de la croix rouge mondiale mais
également de la diaspora libanaise où
vous l'avez déjà alors que les lits dans
wii alors du coup dans cette dans ces
conditions marie noëlle canal chez ma
vie est ce que les médecins sont
inquiets d'une peau sans une potentielle
surcharge des dans les hôpitaux
en fait on y attaquer mais mais l'état
déjà le fait de le prendre ces mesures
d'urgence d'avoir en fait les mesures un
peu ces mesures comment dire les mesures
barrières pour freiner la progression du
virus serait en fait pour gagner le
temps pour gagner du temps parce que
notre notre stock
quand je voulais dit notre stock
d'équipements médicaux est presque
terminée on n'a pas assez de médicaments
mais en même temps nos hôpitaux sont
très bien équipés en matière de
personnel soignant
nous avons parmi les meilleurs médecins
du moyen orient
des virologues les infectiologues les
urgentistes des réanimateurs on manque
pas un seul hier
jusqu'à présent il ya aussi pas mal de
volontaires de bénévoles
ils veulent bien aussi aider leur pays à
dépasser cette crise il faut aussi
souligner que le nombre de lui et il est
limité mais j'ai déjà précisé que
certains hôpitaux
même les hôpitaux privés ils veulent
bien ouvrir deux ailes privé pour
accueillir les patients du coït 19
bien entendu pas tous les établissements
de santé peuvent le faire parce que
certains établissements de santé pour
particulièrement plus fragiles ils n'ont
pas les moyens financiers peut-être ils
ont des patients cancéreux des greffés
raynaud des patients hémodialysés qui
chopin je ne sais pas il faut pas les
mettre à risque et donc peut-être il
faut pas accepter dans tous les hôpitaux
des cas de collier 19
cependant il faut dire que je note que
que toutes les urgences sont en train
d'accepter dans les unités isolées les
cas suspect de covile 19 et que le texte
du corona duruy il est maintenant
presque disponible sur tout le
territoire albanais et que au cas où le
test est positif
les cas sont transférés d'une façon
assez professionnel vers les hôpitaux
qui accueillent les cas merci merci
beaucoup
marie noëlle qu'a lâché manises rappelle
que vous êtes médecin endocrinologue
avec